[Music]
on this monday night thousands of u.s
troops put on high alert we are working
for the best we are hoping for the best
what can and what will nato do to
support ukraine if russia attacks our
crystal commansing is on the ground in
kiev ukraine tonight what is canada
prepared to do to support ukraine plus
an apparent cyber attack on canada's
department of global affairs easily
exploited how human smugglers can prey
on migrants seeking a better life in
canada we don't know about law it's easy
anyone to use you
and a hole-in-one hero the amateur
golfer who repeatedly defies the odds
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
russia and nato countries appear to be
moving closer to a war footing tonight
over ukraine the u.s has placed more
than 8 000 troops on heightened alert
ready to deploy as part of a nato
defense force nato is moving more
military equipment east into eastern
europe a response to russia's rapid
buildup of its troops along ukraine's
border canada calls russia's actions
aggressive and says they must be
deterred but what options and what
leverage does canada have and is a
diplomatic solution still possible
we have complete coverage tonight from
ottawa and from washington dc and we
begin with crystal gemansing who is in
kiev the capital of ukraine tonight
crystal
donna there is a steadfast resilience
here people are obviously talking about
russia and the possibility that their
borders will be invaded once again
people here know the military might of
their neighbors but they're not
panicking people are calm they're united
and they are planning
they are intimidating images russian
military equipment headed for belarus a
russian ally bordering ukraine to the
north ukrainians are countering and
signing up to serve
for some it's their first time others
like dimitrio dubas are returning i saw
a lot of newcomers
who came for the training a lot of women
a lot of people will join the army or
try to
fight
to defend their city they defend their
their families united and willing to
fight for their country but dubai says
none of this is new for ukrainians the
threat of russia he says never fades it
is a lifestyle but even for this combat
veteran the thought of another invasion
is difficult
it started to literally disturb me
i
got some you know
psychological issues and
i
ask about help my psychologist uh and
then like it
it was like two hours enough for me that
and to understand that everything under
control
and
they have to do what they can for him
that means surrounding himself with
friends and training but also
stockpiling of food and water in case of
an emergency
the memory of russia's 2014 annexation
of crimea haunts many ukrainians world
leaders are vowing they are not alone
this time the nato presence is in no way
threatening
because it is
compared to the significant military
buildup by russia and around ukraine
nato's secretary general said in
addition to more warships and jets
deployed to eastern europe it's also
considering sending battle groups to the
baltic region and to the southeast calls
for support for ukraine have come for
weeks now but nato's unity is being
tested and russia
hasn't backed down we are working for
the best we are hoping for the best but
we have to be prepared prepared for the
worst
here the hope is that russia is just
playing politics and using ukraine to
get the attention of the west still no
one is willing to bet that they know
what vladimir putin will or will not do
donna
all right crystal commencing in keeve
tonight thanks in the last 24 hours
there have been more signs washington
considers a russian invasion inevitable
the u.s has ordered families of embassy
staff in kiev to leave and the pentagon
has put thousands of troops on
heightened alert to deploy if needed
jackson proskow reports on the tensions
and whether there are any signs of
de-escalation
convinced a russian invasion of ukraine
is inevitable u.s president joe biden
returned from a weekend of briefings at
camp david armed with new options for
countering the threat it's very clear
that the russians have
no intention right now of de-escalating
the pentagon has put thousands of u.s
troops on heightened alert for potential
deployment if russia invades ukraine
american reinforcements would be sent to
nato's eastern flank poland romania and
the baltic states
vladimir putin has demanded those
countries break existing ties with nato
just as he wants ukraine kept out of the
western alliance it's proving how
seriously the united states takes our
commitment to nato officially the u.s is
still looking for some way to convince
putin to change course russia has tens
of thousands of troops on the border of
ukraine they have the power to
de-escalate we would certainly welcome
that at the u.s embassy in kiev signs of
waning american confidence diplomats and
their families have been sent home u.s
citizens warned to leave the country
immediately
in ukraine experts believe putin is keen
to take advantage of a moment of
political chaos and disunity in the west
to get exactly what he wants
it's a pretty opportune time to try to
undo something which has largely plain
played out on his watch and that is
nato's gradual movement eastward in a
private call with european leaders on
monday biden stressed the need for unity
and reiterated u.s commitments for now
that does not include any promise to
send additional u.s forces into ukraine
the biden administration believes that
combination of threats both sanctions
and an increased military presence send
a strong enough message for now but if
talks with moscow break down or fail to
progress the american posture could
quickly change
donna
okay jackson thanks well what role
canada can play in deterring russia and
supporting ukraine is still being worked
out it is on the agenda of a virtual
cabinet retreat the prime minister is
hosting at the same time government
sources tell global news there's been a
cyber attack on the federal department
of global affairs and russia is
suspected of being behind it our ottawa
bureau chief mercedes stephenson has
more information on that mercedes
donna the attack began on friday but
canadian security agencies are still
actively dealing with the fallout as we
speak tonight sources are describing the
multi-day disruption as substantial and
both government and security sources
tell global news russia or russian-based
hackers are believed to be behind it the
cyber attack comes after the canadian a
canadian intelligence agency warned of
an impending russian attack or attacks
last week sources believe the cyber
attack is in retaliation for foreign
affairs minister melanie jo lee's trip
to ukraine and a canadian promise of 120
million dollar loan to kiev it's unclear
how much damage the attack may have
caused or whether any information was
compromised or stolen sources say the
government expects more potential
attacks in the future
and mercedes is there any news today on
what canada is prepared to do to support
ukraine and our nato allies both
militarily and diplomatically
well donna the ukrainian government has
asked canada for weapons and more troops
right now there are about 200 canadians
on a training mission in ukraine known
as operation unifier sources tell global
news that the canadian government is
likely to approve a request for weapons
and that is in front of cabinet right
now if cabinet agrees to that the
canadian armed forces will deliver small
arms and ammunition that means pistols
rifles machine guns sniper rifles and
all the bullets and optics that would go
along with them the canadian military
has already started moving those stocks
into position if cabinet does approve
them but to be clear this is not a
massive amount of weapons we're talking
about we're talking about hundreds not
thousands of guns this is what the prime
minister had to say about the
government's support for ukraine
we will continue
to work closely with the government of
ukraine to ensure they get the support
they need
and i'm sure there will be more
announcements to come
the prime minister is expected to make
an announcement on wednesday we'll find
out what that is the government is
trying to send a strong message to
russia without antagonizing them and
nothing of course will be done donna
without coordination of our allies
all right mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks the florida man charged with
human smuggling in connection with four
deaths at the manitoba u.s border will
be released from custody in the u.s 47
year old steve shand appeared virtually
in a minnesota courtroom today he must
surrender his passport shand will remain
in custody until transportation back to
his florida home is arranged manitoba
rcmp say they have not yet confirmed the
identities of those four victims the
tragic loss of life on that frozen
manitoba field has prompted many
questions human smugglers prey on the
desperation of people searching for a
better life heather yurix west spoke
with one man who turned to human
smugglers about what drove him to do it
and his advice to others
mohamed alajama has traveled a difficult
road to get here originally from jordan
he spent years dreaming of a better life
i want like move from my country i have
like my own story my own problem but
soon after arriving in the u.s he was
contacted by a cousin who promised that
life could be found in canada
alejandra would just need to pay someone
he thought was a lawyer to help
facilitate the journey in reality he was
about to enter the world of human
smuggling he asked for money for four
thousand dollar u.s
to get me in he told me like you can
get your
citizen here in canada
and get like better life and job
in like in two months you get your
pr it wasn't true
once in canada without official
immigration status or a right to work
alojirma became indebted to his smuggler
he began working for the man as a driver
eventually learning he was being used to
smuggle other migrants into canada as he
had been you think you are money that's
it with elijah's help the canadian
border services agency charged the man
responsible for the smuggling operation
but advocates say vulnerabilities remain
i think the word smuggling is incorrect
by and large people are looking for
paths to be able to reunite with their
family get decent work access to basic
services
sayyid hassan says migrants can easily
become desperate on either side of the
canada u.s border because despite its
welcoming reputation canada can be a
very difficult place for migrants
without permanent residency rights
that's three quarters of a million
people coming on study permits work from
its refugees who aren't able to access
any basic services are being exploited
at work cannot be with their families
with the help of a new lawyer alejandra
was eventually able to claim asylum here
as a refugee hopeful now he can at last
realize his dreams we want a peace we
want to live life normal good life
walk morning go do your job finish go
home like that's what we need a modest
ambition for someone who's endured so
much
heather urex west global news calgary
nunavut is the latest to sign on to the
federal government's child care program
the 66 million dollar five-year deal
aims to cut daycare fees in half by the
end of this year and reduce them to ten
dollars a day by march 2024 it also
promises to create over 200 new spaces
over the next two years
we'll continue working with
representative inuit organizations to
ensure that children have access to
inuit specific indigenous child care
through indigenous early learning and
child care as
well
prime minister trudeau says the deal
will save families in a calorie an
average of fourteen thousand dollars a
year ontario is the only province that
hasn't signed on to the federal program
coming up quebec shoppers be warned why
some people are barred from big box
stores plus what canadians think about
whether the unboxed should be taxed
quebec has expanded the requirement for
vaccine passports shoppers must now show
they are fully vaccinated before being
allowed to enter big box stores like
canadian tire costco or walmart
pharmacies and grocery stores are exempt
across the country people are divided
about whether unvaccinated canadians
should be penalized less than 20 percent
of the population is unvaccinated
against covid19 now coupled with the
rising concerns about the omicron wave
new polling done exclusively for global
news shows most canadians are in favor
of imposing more restrictions jamie
morocco reports
[Music]
in a week toronto dance teacher alex
cyan won't be on this floor alone his
students will be allowed back in studio
wearing masks if fully vaccinated if the
larger population is vaccinated that
means we can come out of the sooner
remove the restrictions and be back to a
new version of normal new ipsos polling
exclusive to global news reveals nearly
half of canadians say unvaccinated are
responsible for prolonging the pandemic
in canada and two-thirds want
governments to impose even further
measures on the unvaccinated population
politicians are walking the tightrope
the tightrope between public opinion on
one hand
and the reality on the ground ontario
and bc are moving forward with lifting
restrictions following immense pressure
from business owners but quebec's
premier francois lego isn't budging
musing controversially about taxing the
unvaccinated
i think it's normal that the majority
the population is asking
that there be a consequence a popular
idea in quebec and nationally with more
than half of canadians polled in support
toronto-based chiropractor kyle kacchi
works on vaccinated and unvaccinated
patients i see many different angles of
this entire discussion this entire topic
so to me i don't i don't feel more quote
unquote unsafe if someone's unback stand
here what's perhaps more concerning to
him is how divisive this topic has
become nobody's going to tie you down
down and stick a needle in your arm
bioethics professor vardit ravitsky
rejects the notion vaccine mandates are
a form of medical coercion right now
people are paying themselves for the
burden on the health care system when it
gets to that point
uh increasing the pressure on those who
are unvaccinated by choice is legitimate
but these tactics can't be used forever
as we emerge from the pandemic
gradually as our healthcare system goes
back to functioning normally we should
reduce the pressure
until then both business owners know
vaccination debate will continue to
polarize
it's unfortunate that it's come down to
this where you feel like we have to do
this in order to get in a better
position come the summer and come next
next fall looking forward to a future
where one's vaccination status doesn't
create such deep divides jamie morocco
global news toronto
traveling to parts of the uk will soon
get easier for people who are fully
vaccinated the british government says
starting february 11 fully vaccinated
people will no longer need a covid19
test to enter for now the change applies
only to england and scotland rules are
also being eased for unvaccinated
travelers they'll still need a covered
test to enter but they'll no longer have
to quarantine
[Music]
ahead how a stowaway in amsterdam
survived a flight from africa
[Music]
you're watching global national
[Music]
after days of heavy gunfire in burkina
faso's capital the military declared it
has taken control of the west african
nation and ousted the president video
shows armored vehicles belonging to the
presidential guard riddled with bullet
holes and covered in blood near the
president's residence there are reports
he's being held in a camp at an unknown
location the military says board the
borders will be closed in a nightly
curfew imposed until further notice the
deposed president faced growing
discontent over his failure to stem an
islamist insurgency
in the netherlands a man is recovering
in the hospital after surviving a flight
from africa as a stowaway in the wheel
well of an airplane police say the man
was found on a flight that had just
arrived from south africa via kenya he
was still breathing despite enduring
hours of extreme cold and low oxygen
levels he's since been identified as a
22 year old kenyan police say the man
has applied for asylum and they're now
investigating how he got onto that plane
and whether it's a case of human
smuggling
nasa scientists now say the force of
that volcano that rocked tonga and
triggered a tsunami 10 days ago was
hundreds of times stronger than the
atomic bomb dropped on hiroshima japan
in 1945.
the bomb was estimated to be about 15
000 tons of tnt a powerful explosive
substance scientists say the energy
released by the volcanic eruption was
between 5 and 30 million tons
nasa's earth observatory also believes
the volcano shot debris as high as 40
kilometers into the atmosphere
one swing wonder next an amateur
golfer's unstoppable hot streak
it is the holy grail of golfing sinking
the ball in just one shot what makes a
hole in one so unlikely is obvious a
tiny ball of course hit across a vast
distance this next story is even more
remarkable because an amateur golfer in
the uk has done it not once but 11 times
as mike delay explains everyone's trying
to figure out how
via watts doesn't exactly turn heads on
the golf course his swing is
well more like a slap shot yet this 40
year old brit is the talk of the golf
world for his sudden knack at hitting
holes in one
he hit his first six months ago he's now
up to 11 including this one while
shooting an interview with a local news
station hold it up hold it up that's
great the odds are long to do it once
twelve thousand five hundred to one
every other week from there i started
getting a hole in one and it was just
getting to the stage where it was like
oh god let me what's going on the other
golfers at the course didn't care for an
explanation golfing tradition dictates
that any golfer who hits an ace buys
drinks at the bar afterwards the first
two cost me quite a bit of money but
afterwards i managed to quickly get in
the car and go home straight after so it
didn't cost me too much that afterwards
in truth there are few sports as
frustrating as golf a four-letter word
if there ever was one speaking of four
remember that four-year-old who hit an
ace
get in the hole go in the hole
what
he'll be talking about it the rest of
his life
as with this guy
who knew almost immediately there was
one way to go after hitting the golfing
summit
i've never hit an again i'm just
quitting most golfers dream of hitting
one watts for all his success is now
aiming for twenty
microlight global news toronto
wild and that is global national for
this monday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is some good old pond hockey
in lewisport newfoundland and labrador
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
you